before we go just time for a visit to
the very large red chair so who's there
who's there hi hello who are you I'm Mia
Mia lovely and uh where are you from Mia
I'm from Lester Lester top of the
league never has a town got
less are you at the show by yourself uh
no I'm with some friends who from L de
oh so they couldn't even be bothered to
cheer your poor friend is in the chair
going last sit in your
hands she wanted to do it I'm not
cheering cheering I'm not
cheering and do you live here now no no
I'm I'm on Easter holiday so I'm just
visiting what a lovely holiday
destination you've
chosen she off for the brexit okay so
I'll you going with this story M so I
was at a University reunion um in basow
is up up north some my a big country
house um we've not seen each other in a
while
sorry so just having drinks went to the
pub git Larry at the pub No Pants dance
teddy bear rolls just standed on a night
out we go back have some more drinks um
and then me and my friend go to get some
drinks in the utility room and it's
winter it's just the winter just gone so
it's really cold and the door shuts and
there's no handle on the other side of
the door so we're like oh this is the
utility room no drinks in here anyway
banging on the door banging on the door
half an hour an hour an hour and a half
they've all gone to bed as soon we get
to bed we realized that we're stuck in
this utility room it's aboutus 3° and
there's a dog basket and uh some coats
and we've watched a bit of bad grills I
think we're just going to maybe have to
get in the dog basket with my friend's
parents coats all around is try to make
some bed and realize that you have to
sort take your clothes off to stay
really warm because it was really really
cold gram it really was and
then no one's coming we're banging on
the door we've got no phones there's no
toilet I really really need need a Wei
at this point there's just a bowl so
with the dog basket you know that that
happens then one thing leads to
another in the dog basket and he gets
injured anyway um okay there are so many
bits of this story
missing so you're having sex in a dog
basket I'm not I'm absolutely not one
thing L to another what else would that
mean I just knew you'd make that in and
he gets injured there's a lot of blood
everywhere the
dog there's no dog pull the l pull the L
gra I don't going to pull
[Applause]
the love
that begging those people over there you
are not her
friends yeah no tell that story tell it
be good the one the one where a guy
bleeds in a dog basket while you're
having sex with him is that the first
time someone's pulled the LA on I think
it's the first time we've had Harry car
on
the too much I can't I don't know where
this story is going now before we go we
would just like to say a special thank
you and good night to the man who
inspired our red share the great Ronnie
Corbett who was died at the age of 85 he
was always one of our favorite guests
here on the
show and we just wanted to send our love
and sympathy to Anne and the family
[Music]
[Applause]
embarrassed why would you be embarrassed
lots of hairy men standing around
watching you imagine what dogging feels
like